joining me now is texas senator ted cruz
senator
um you have become as well a popular
target of the left they they're trying
to
decouple any republican uh who has a
connection
to the base and the intellectual
chops to actually make a coherent
argument across the board
well look the left right now they feel
resurgent
and and for them it's about power they
want to hold on to power they want to
expand
power and when they have their power
they want to ram through
their their socialist vision for this
country you know i was listening to to
your opening monologue and i i think you
think it
is exactly right you look at the left
and and
far too many in the republican party
also and for a long time they have been
on board with with essentially what i'd
call america last
standing with our enemies standing with
the chinese communist government
standing with unlimited open borders and
standing against the working men and
women and i think the most significant
political change of the last decade has
been
that the heart and soul of the
republican party we are a working-class
party now we are a blue-collar party
that's what we should have been and
that's what we are and if we're standing
with the men and women who want to work
right now look at the democratic party
they want to close your businesses
they want your kids to stay home they
close the schools open
borders abolish the police make your
life less safe your kids left safe your
family less safe
they side with our enemies and they
abandon our friends it's all completely
backwards
but the good news is also what you just
said they're revealing exactly who they
are
what does it say that the governor of
new york and the governor of california
are both in free fall
their ideas don't work and we're sadly
going to see that
play out more and more over the next two
years i think that's going to lead us to
a very good 2022 and a very good 2024.
yeah we need a 50-state movement again
it can't be cobbling together things
with texas
you know they're going to try to exploit
the power grid failure in texas
obviously that's going to happen we got
to have a 50-state movement this
this hodgepodge of a few rust belt
states and you know
turn around three times and hope you're
gonna win the majority it's just i i
think it's gotta be
much broader but senator the new dhs
secretary
uh he was out there today he was asked
whether he thought there was a crisis
at our southern border watch
i think that the the answer is no
i think there is a challenge at the
border it is a stressful challenge
we are not only in addressing the
urgency of the challenge
but also in building the capacity to
manage it
and to meet our humanitarian aspirations
and execution of the president's vision
senator cruz building the capacity to
manage the flow
that he is personally encouraging as i
showed in the angle well you know the
the democrats are magicians
uh you remember we had four years of
news stories about
kids in cages well those cages are being
expanded they're being reopened now that
biden's running them
they're simply safe humanitarian
locations of course obama built the
cages and the reason we have
little boys and little girls being
brought in by human traffickers
is because of obama's amnesty program
that that served as a magnet to begin
with but but
you know when when the dhs secretary
says there isn't a crisis at the border
from his perspective he believes that
because there's an old joke that that
the term illegal alien is no longer
politically correct
the new term is undocumented democrat
from his perspective every person coming
here illegally
is another prospective voter and the
democratic party has abandoned
the working-class men and women the
millions of people who are out of jobs
who are seeing their wages pulled down
who are competing to provide for their
families with people coming
illegally that's not who the democratic
party represents anymore they don't
represent unions anymore they don't
represent construction workers or truck
drivers or working men and women anymore
the democratic party today is the party
of wealthy elites on both coasts
it's the party of big tech and big
business it's the party of
of universities and from their
perspective
the more cheap labor that flows in
particularly
if they vote democrat the better now
we need to be standing with americans we
need to be standing for
jobs and you know you were talking about
a 50-state movement
i want to point out the democrats agenda
is truly radical what does it say even
california
is recalling gavin newsom when you shut
down schools you know
40 percent of kids k-12 right now or
going to in-person school
60 percent are not that's a generation
of kids being left behind
a significant chunk of whom are black or
or
or hispanic and the democrats are
abandoning them this is an opportunity
for
common sense and and i think that's what
we ought to be fighting yeah
senator real quick one yes or no should
we
boycott the 2022 beijing games
uh to be honest i haven't thought about
that question i'm
generally not a fan of boycotting things
like like boycotting the olympics
senator aren't they committing genocide
ongoing genocide
look they are committing genocide
they've introduced legislation she
why should we give sorry to interrupt
but why should we give xi a big
propaganda coup
by sending our people over there to be
in a packed stadium after they uh
inadvertently or are purposely released
a virus and they're committing on
going genocide how do we as a country
countenance that
because we shouldn't punish american
athletes i think we should go over there
call them out be absolutely explicit
i've introduced legislation
to sanction the officials responsible
for the genocide
to fight them and call them out directly
but you know when jimmy carter boycotted
the olympics i didn't think it was a
very good policy
i think hurting american athletes is a
policy of weakness but
but the answer we shouldn't do
is is to do what a lot of all the
democrats and a lot of republicans will
want to do which is go over there
and kiss she's behind we need to speak
the truth
and call them out unequivocally it's a
oh you and i do
we you and i part ways there but i
appreciate your answering the question
senator thank you so much for coming on